From writing emails to reading CAT scans, millions of people across a wide range of professions now use AI tools to help them do their jobs. In many cases, these tools save time and make us more productive. But as workers increasingly rely on AI tools for critical job tasks, some psychologists are asking, what will happen to our own skills as we hand over more work to artificial intelligence? People have worried about losing skills to technology before. We have GPS, so we rarely bother to look at maps anymore. Calculators change the way we do math. And in aviation, experts have long studied how autopilot affects pilot's skills.
从撰写电子邮件到阅读计算机断层扫描（CT）影像，数以百万计从事各行各业的人们现在都在使用人工智能工具来辅助工作。在许多情况下，这些工具节省了时间并提高了我们的工作效率。但随着员工越来越依赖人工智能工具来完成关键工作任务，一些心理学家开始提出疑问：当我们把更多的工作交给人工智能时，我们自身的技能会发生什么变化？人们以前也曾担心过因技术而丧失技能。我们有了GPS，所以很少再费心去看地图了。计算器改变了我们做数学题的方式。在航空领域，专家们长期以来一直在研究自动驾驶仪如何影响飞行员的技能。
So is AI just the latest example of this so-called cognitive offloading? How is it changing the way people learn, remember, and develop expertise? Are some skills more vulnerable to loss than others? Does it matter whether you're a novice or already an expert when you start to use AI? And what can workers do to make sure they're using AI in ways that help rather than hinder their learning and development? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Brooke McNamara.
那么，人工智能是否只是这种所谓的“认知卸载”的最新例子？它如何改变人们学习、记忆和培养专业知识的方式？某些技能是否比其他技能更容易丧失？当你开始使用人工智能时，你是新手还是专家，这有关系吗？员工能做些什么来确保他们使用人工智能的方式是促进而非阻碍他们的学习和发展？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是布鲁克·麦克纳马拉（Brooke McNamara）博士。
Dr. McNamara is an associate professional. professor of psychological sciences at Purdue University, where she directs the skill, learning, and performance laboratory. Her work explores how people acquire skills and expertise in professions ranging from elite sports to medicine. She looks at how practice, training, cognitive abilities, the environment and other factors affect skill development. She's currently studying how AI may affect learning and performance, and she recently spoke with APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology for an article on the topic. Dr. McNamara, thank you for joining me today. Thank you. I'm thrilled to be here. I mentioned in the introduction that people have worried about losing skills to technology before.
麦克纳马拉博士是普渡大学心理科学系的副教授，她在那里指导技能、学习与表现实验室。她的工作探索人们如何在从精英体育到医学等各个行业中获得技能和专业知识。她研究练习、培训、认知能力、环境和其他因素如何影响技能发展。她目前正在研究人工智能如何影响学习和表现，最近她还接受了美国心理学会杂志《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）的采访，讨论了这一主题。麦克纳马拉博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢，我很高兴能来到这里。我在介绍中提到，人们以前也曾担心过因技术而丧失技能。
Can you talk about that? I mean, how have we offloaded certain tests to technology and is AI in any way different from these previous technologies? Sure. We've been offloading to technology, even things that we don't think of as technology for quite a long time. So back in 370 Bs, Pledo lamented that we would lose our memories and those skills because we suddenly had writing and that people would then just start using writing and not work on the great memorization that a lot of people had where they would learn stories that could go on for days. And he's not wrong, right? We did lose those skills, but we're okay with them because most of the time we do have access to jotting down ideas.
您能谈谈这一点吗？我的意思是，我们是如何将某些任务卸载给技术的？人工智能与这些之前的技术有什么不同吗？当然。我们进行技术卸载已经有很长一段时间了，甚至包括那些我们并不认为是技术的东西。早在公元前370年，柏拉图就曾感叹，因为我们突然有了书写，我们将失去记忆和那些技能；人们会开始使用书写，而不再去练习许多人曾经拥有的那种伟大的记忆力，即学习可以持续数天的故事。他说得没错，对吧？我们确实失去了那些技能，但我们对此并不介意，因为大多数时候我们确实可以随时记下想法。
And this, of course, has gone through the times where we have lost some of these skills. Depending on the age of the listener, you might remember knowing a lot of phone numbers when you were a kid. Right. And we don't know too many phone numbers these days. But that's something that we're just sort of willing to be okay with that we've lost that. You mentioned GPS. A lot of people, at least anecdotally, don't think that they have the same spatial navigation skills. or will sort of develop a good mental map as quickly as they used to without.
当然，这种情况也经历过我们失去其中一些技能的时期。根据听众的年龄，你可能还记得小时候背过很多电话号码。没错。而如今我们记不住太多电话号码了。但这只是我们某种程度上愿意接受的一种技能丧失。您提到了GPS。很多人，至少从轶事来看，认为他们不再拥有同样的空间导航技能，或者不再像过去那样能够快速形成良好的心理地图。
But again, we usually have access to it. So these are all skills that have indeed, at least for a lot of people, maybe have reduced or atrophied, but generally as a society, we're okay with it. That said, whenever a new technology comes around, there is kind of this panic. So Orban defined it as the Sisyphian cycle of technology. panics. So we're in a state now. So not too long ago, it was the internet and Google. There was a famous article is Google making us stupid. And we're sort of living through the end of one cycle, potentially and moving on into a new one. And the issue is that technology moves pretty quickly,
但同样，我们通常可以使用它。所以，这些确实是至少对许多人来说已经减少或退化的技能，但作为一个社会，我们对此是可以接受的。话虽如此，每当一项新技术出现时，总会有一种恐慌。奥尔班（Orban）将其定义为技术的西西弗斯式循环恐慌。所以我们现在正处于这种状态。不久前，它是互联网和谷歌。有一篇著名的文章问“谷歌是否正在让我们变笨”。我们正处于一个周期的末尾，可能正在进入一个新的周期。问题在于技术发展得非常快，
and science can move less quickly, at least psychological experiments. So how this affects us, we can be a bit behind on knowing how much it affects us. But if we think of skills and knowledge acquisition as use it or lose it, or of course to learn a skill, we have to engage with it. If we are cognitively offloading to something else and we're not engaging in the same way, then there's a good chance that we're not learning the skill as deeply as we would if we didn't have that technology.
而科学的发展速度可能较慢，至少心理学实验是这样。因此，关于这如何影响我们，我们在了解它对我们影响程度方面可能会滞后。但如果我们认为技能和知识的获取是“不用则废”，或者当然，要学习一项技能，我们必须参与其中。如果我们正在进行认知卸载，而没有以同样的方式参与，那么我们很有可能无法像没有这项技术时那样深入地学习这项技能。
Do we know yet whether we're losing skills to AI, especially in the workplace, or is it still too early to know? Well, it's certainly too early to know. We are in the stage where there's early experiments that are starting to come out. Of course, we don't know what will replicate, what will change as the technology changes. But there is some information out there that is potentially concerning. So, for example, there was a study with endoscopists where at a hospital an AI tool was implemented where they had random access to it in terms of being able to detect adenomas, so polyps. And if you look at their detection rate before the AI
我们现在是否知道我们是否正在因人工智能而丧失技能，特别是在工作场所，还是说现在下结论还为时过早？嗯，现在下结论肯定还为时过早。我们正处于早期实验开始出现的阶段。当然，我们不知道哪些结果会重现，哪些会随着技术的发展而改变。但目前确实有一些信息令人担忧。例如，有一项针对内窥镜医师的研究，在一家医院实施了一项人工智能工具，他们可以随机使用该工具来检测腺瘤，即息肉。如果你观察他们在人工智能实施之前的检测率，
was implemented, and then this randomly, when it was taken away, their detection rates fell. So it suggests that they potentially lost some of that skill and how well they could detect without, the AI available, that they've gotten used to the AI being available. There was another study that found that medical professional skills, like basic life support, decayed when people didn't use them. And this was roughly decayed by about 50%, so 40 to 60%, after six months of disuse. So if we are offloading to AI and not really using these skills to the same degree, there's a good chance that those skills will decay. So speaking of whether Google makes us stupid, I mean, that's an interesting article and
然后当它被随机移除时，他们的检测率下降了。这表明他们可能失去了一些在没有人工智能辅助下进行检测的技能，因为他们已经习惯了人工智能的可用性。另一项研究发现，当人们不使用医疗专业技能（如基础生命支持）时，这些技能就会退化。在停止使用六个月后，这些技能大约退化了50%，即40%到60%。因此，如果我们正在向人工智能卸载，而没有真正以同样的程度使用这些技能，那么这些技能很有可能会退化。说到谷歌是否让我们变笨，那是一篇有趣的文章，
actually dates to 2008. And of course, the author wrote about this lack of attention span, that he couldn't read a whole book anymore the way that he used to. And I'm just wondering if this is the kind of thing that we should fear with AI as well. I mean, are there things that we can do to keep those skills sharp? Sure. So, Cognitive offloading isn't kind of an on-off switch. So it depends on how we're engaging with the AI tool and how much of the work we're cognitively offloading. For example, if someone is trying to learn a new skill, but in that process, they're really just asking AI for the answer every time. They'll get some exposure. They'll probably learn a little bit, but not as much as if
实际上可以追溯到2008年。当然，作者写到了注意力广度的缺失，他无法再像过去那样阅读整本书了。我只是想知道，这是否也是我们应该对人工智能感到恐惧的事情？我的意思是，我们能做些什么来保持这些技能的敏锐度吗？当然。所以，认知卸载并不是一种“开-关”开关。这取决于我们如何与人工智能工具互动，以及我们在认知上卸载了多少工作。例如，如果有人试图学习一项新技能，但在过程中，他们每次都只是向人工智能索要答案。他们会得到一些接触，可能会学到一点，但不会像他们尝试进行所谓的“理想难度”练习那样学得多。
they were trying to engage in what are called desirable difficulties, right? So if they are trying to generate the answer themselves or test themselves, what's called retrieval practice, to try to remember the answers. They'll learn the skill better that way. So if they completely offload, probably they won't learn that new skill to the same degree as if they didn't have the tool. But there are other cases where you could use the AI to check your answer or give you examples, ways where you're interacting and engaging and you're not just completely offloading all of the cognitive work, where you really are using it as a support system. In which case, there's evidence out there that suggests in some case you do better if you have that AI support,
所以，如果他们尝试自己生成答案或测试自己，即所谓的“提取练习”，试图记住答案。他们会以那种方式更好地学习这项技能。因此，如果他们完全卸载，他们可能无法像没有该工具时那样深入地学习这项新技能。但还有其他情况，你可以使用人工智能来检查你的答案或为你提供示例，在这种方式下，你是在互动和参与，而不是完全卸载所有的认知工作，你确实是在把它作为一个支持系统来使用。在这种情况下，有证据表明，在某些情况下，如果你有这种人工智能支持，你会做得更好，
or in some cases you're at least not doing as poorly as if you are completely cognitively offloading. So it really depends on how we're using it. Are there other tips and tricks? I mean, because some AI will basically not only give you the answer when you ask a question, then it will ask you if you want to know these five other things. I mean, maybe you as the users should be thinking of what you need and not relying on AI to tell you. And here's the next question you should ask me. Right, right. So there's always the question of are we losing critical thinking skills by offloading that part to AI. And there's evidence that maybe we are. Interestingly, since we were just talking about Google and people having concerns about it, now there's been studies comparing Googling things to using AI. And in those cases, so well, this is a study, I guess I should say. We don't have a lot of data yet.
或者在某些情况下，至少不会像完全进行认知卸载时那样表现糟糕。所以这确实取决于我们如何使用它。还有其他技巧吗？我的意思是，因为有些人工智能不仅会在你提问时给你答案，还会问你是否想知道其他五件事。我的意思是，也许作为用户，你应该考虑你需要什么，而不是依赖人工智能来告诉你。这是你应该问我的下一个问题。没错，没错。所以总是存在一个问题：我们是否通过将那部分工作卸载给人工智能而失去了批判性思维能力？有证据表明我们可能正在失去。有趣的是，既然我们刚才谈到了谷歌和人们对它的担忧，现在已经有研究将谷歌搜索与使用人工智能进行了比较。在这些情况下，嗯，我想我应该说这是一项研究。我们目前还没有太多数据。
Actually, it was one paper of multiple studies where people were asked to learn about something. and then give advice to a friend on the topic. So how to plant a vegetable garden, how to live a healthy lifestyle. And either they Googled information on a few pages and then synthesized it themselves and then gave that advice, or they used AI, which of course synthesized it for them. And what they found is that for those who used AI, the advice they gave was briefer, it was less unique to the person, and it was rated as less helpful than it. if they used Google. And the idea is that AI was sort of doing that cognitive work for you. You put in
实际上，有一篇论文包含多项研究，人们被要求学习某件事，然后就该主题向朋友提供建议。比如如何种植菜园，如何过健康的生活方式。他们要么在几个页面上搜索信息，然后自己进行综合，然后给出建议；要么使用人工智能，当然，人工智能为他们进行了综合。他们发现，对于那些使用人工智能的人来说，他们给出的建议更简短，对个人而言更缺乏独特性，并且被评价为不如使用谷歌的人给出的建议有帮助。其理念是，人工智能在为你做那种认知工作。你投入的
less effort and you weren't having to synthesize that information yourself. You weren't having to go in, read multiple tabs, think about how it all works together and then produce that advice. It was just given to you. And therefore, it was less interesting and the person didn't seem to learn as much. It sounds like the good old days of the World Book Encyclopedia where that was all we had and you would have to go in and read it and synthesize it yourself. So what you're saying is doing a little bit more of the work yourself is advisable at this point if you want to stay sharp. Certainly that's some advice. Now, of course, nobody is suggesting that you give up on computers and the Internet and go back to the library and having to pull up each encyclopedia at a time, right? Nobody wants to live that way because there's a lot of benefits, of course, to technology.
努力更少，而且你不需要自己去综合这些信息。你不需要进入多个标签页，思考它们是如何协同工作的，然后产生这些建议。它只是直接给你的。因此，它不那么有趣，而且那个人似乎学到的东西也更少。这听起来像是《世界图书百科全书》的美好旧时光，那时我们只有这些，你必须进去阅读并自己进行综合。所以你的意思是，如果你想保持敏锐，目前建议自己多做一点工作。当然，这是一种建议。现在，当然，没有人建议你放弃电脑和互联网，回到图书馆，不得不一次取出一本百科全书，对吧？没有人想那样生活，因为技术当然有很多好处。
So Google is much faster. It is at your fingertips. So it's more about, right, how you're engaging with the technology and how much you're offloading. But yes, absolutely. I think the more that you engage with the skill yourself, test yourself on how well you know the information or can perform the task without AI is important because there's also the possibility that we are overcome confident in our skills with AI. So if you're engaging with the task with AI, probably your performance is better than if you weren't using AI. But if that AI is taken away, what is your skill level? But because you've been performing the task at a very high level, it's possible that you're mistaking your competency for what is essentially your competency plus the AI's competency. So it might
所以谷歌快得多。它就在你的指尖。所以这更多是关于你如何与技术互动以及你卸载了多少。但是，是的，绝对是。我认为你越是亲自参与这项技能，测试自己对信息的了解程度或在没有人工智能的情况下执行任务的能力，就越重要，因为我们也可能对人工智能辅助下的技能过于自信。所以，如果你在人工智能的辅助下完成任务，你的表现可能比不使用人工智能时要好。但如果人工智能被拿走，你的技能水平如何？但因为你一直以很高的水平执行任务，你可能会把你的能力误认为是你的能力加上人工智能的能力。所以可能
be good also to test your skills without it to see what your actual competency is. And this is something done, so for example, autopilot, which of course is not AI. It's an automation. In other words, if you have the same environment, it'll do the same thing every time, which of course is different from AI, which is learning and adapting and making decisions that were previously the domain of the expert alone. But in aviation, autopilot, the FAA is concerned that, pilots' skills are atrophying, that they're not performing as well. And so there's strong recommendations that pilots go through an entire flight using manual control because they're concerned that those skills are being lost. Well, now we're talking a little bit about
在没有它的情况下测试你的技能以了解你的实际能力也是好的。这是一个已经完成的事情，例如，自动驾驶仪，当然它不是人工智能。它是一种自动化。换句话说，如果你有相同的环境，它每次都会做同样的事情，这当然不同于人工智能，人工智能是在学习、适应并做出以前仅属于专家领域决策的系统。但在航空领域，自动驾驶仪方面，美国联邦航空管理局（FAA）担心飞行员的技能正在退化，他们的表现不如以前。因此，有强烈的建议要求飞行员在整个飞行过程中使用手动控制，因为他们担心这些技能正在丧失。好吧，现在我们谈论了一点
expertise here, and I know you studied that. How might using AI affect novices like medical residents differently from experts like experienced surgeons? Right. There's, again, limited evidence, but some evidence to suggest that these are different processes. So this is outside of the workplace, but for example, there was a study looking at using AI to learn math. And so if you're learning a new skill, or even with calculators, going back even sort of more basic, with calculators, if a kid is learning a new math skill, but with a calculator, they tend to not learn it as well, as if they needed to try to generate the answer themselves and then use the calculator as a check. But for kids who already had those math skills and then used a calculator, it didn't matter.
专业知识，我知道你研究过这个。使用人工智能对医学住院医师等新手与经验丰富的外科医生等专家有何不同影响？没错。同样，证据有限，但有一些证据表明这些是不同的过程。这不在工作场所，但例如，有一项研究着眼于使用人工智能学习数学。所以如果你正在学习一项新技能，或者即使是使用计算器，回到更基础的层面，使用计算器，如果一个孩子正在学习一项新的数学技能，但使用计算器，他们往往学得不如他们需要尝试自己生成答案然后使用计算器作为检查时那么好。但对于那些已经具备这些数学技能然后使用计算器的孩子来说，这没有影响。
It didn't affect those skills. Now, long term, if the study had looked for a very long time with those skills, have atrophied in the kids, possibly. So in the workplace, there's the idea of, okay, what's happening during training, where you're learning a new skill, and then once you've already hit a level of expertise, but now you're just relying on the AI, do your skills decay. So there's a bit of evidence for both of those. It's likely the case that if you know a skill really well, it's going to take much longer for the skill to decay to have that disuse.
它没有影响那些技能。现在，从长远来看，如果研究观察了很长一段时间，这些技能在孩子身上是否会退化，有可能。因此，在工作场所，存在一种想法，即在培训期间发生了什么，你正在学习一项新技能，然后一旦你已经达到了一定的专业水平，但现在你只是依赖人工智能，你的技能会退化吗？所以这两者都有一些证据。很可能的情况是，如果你非常了解一项技能，那么该技能因停止使用而退化将需要更长的时间。
We have that study that I mentioned that after about six months of disuse, that those skills start to decay by about 50%. Now, that's complete disuse. Using the AI and cognitively offloading isn't complete disuse. So it's probably a bit slower than that. But I think it's something that we still need to be concerned about. If someone's skills are starting to decline because they're relying on AI, will they even notice it?
我们有我提到的那项研究，即在停止使用约六个月后，这些技能开始退化约50%。现在，那是完全停止使用。使用人工智能并进行认知卸载并不是完全停止使用。所以它可能比那要慢一些。但我认为这仍然是我们需要担心的事情。如果某人的技能因为依赖人工智能而开始下降，他们会注意到吗？
I mean, is it obvious to people that they're leaning on AI and they don't really know what they're doing themselves? Quite possibly they would be completely unaware of it. It's going to depend on how they're using the AI, most likely. But absolutely, if the AI is sort of picking up the slack, so to speak, at every turn, and keeping that inside a black box so that they don't even know that it's happening, absolutely, we could be caught unaware, which could potentially be an issue in, say, cases in medicine where not only maybe the AI is not available or gets updated and it's different
我的意思是，人们是否明显感觉到他们在依赖人工智能，而自己并不知道自己在做什么？很有可能他们会完全没有意识到这一点。这很可能取决于他们如何使用人工智能。但绝对地，如果人工智能在每一个转折点都在“弥补不足”，并将其保持在一个黑匣子内，以至于他们甚至不知道发生了什么，那么我们绝对可能会在不知不觉中被困住，这在医学等案例中可能是一个问题，不仅是因为人工智能可能不可用，或者被更新了，而且它不同了，
and you don't know how to use it. So you're a surgeon using a robot, and this is a bit more in the future because the AI isn't really set in there, but that's a goal in terms of the future of work. So now the AI isn't working. Can you still perform the surgery? So there's that aspect that we need to be concerned about.
你不知道如何使用它。所以你是一名使用机器人的外科医生，这在未来会更多一些，因为人工智能并没有真正设置在那里，但这是未来工作的一个目标。所以现在人工智能不工作了。你还能进行手术吗？所以我们需要担心这方面。
I'm just wondering, since you're studying AI in professions that include things like elite sports, how does AI influence somebody who is an elite athlete athlete? I mean, you still have to perform if that's what you do. So what is AI doing for you and are you actually offloading anything to AI when you are an athlete? There is probably less that you're offloading. There could be decisions that you're making or learning or skills, but you're going to
我只是想知道，既然你在研究包括精英体育在内的职业中的人工智能，人工智能如何影响精英运动员？我的意思是，如果那是你的工作，你仍然必须表现。那么人工智能为你做了什么？当你是一名运动员时，你实际上是在向人工智能卸载任何东西吗？你卸载的东西可能更少。你可能正在做出决定或学习或技能，但你将
essentially be forced to test yourself without AI present. As of now, there's not, you know, AI and a racket for a tennis player to be told at the moment like, no, go for the spin. They're about to do this. So I think for now at least probably that's pretty safe as opposed to, again, going back to medicine where not only maybe the AI is unavailable, but maybe the AI is available, but we get, say, a novel coronavirus. And so we don't have the data needed for machine learning. for AI to be able to make decisions. We want to make sure that our medical professionals
基本上被迫在没有人工智能的情况下测试自己。到目前为止，还没有，你知道，网球运动员的球拍里有人工智能，在当下被告知“不，去旋转吧”。他们正要这样做。所以我认为至少目前为止，这可能是相当安全的，而不是，再次回到医学领域，不仅人工智能可能不可用，而且可能人工智能可用，但我们遇到了，比如说，一种新型冠状病毒。所以我们没有机器学习所需的数据。为了让人工智能能够做出决定。我们想确保我们的医疗专业人员
can still reason and think through information in those cases where the AI isn't going to be available for a different reason. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. McNamara about how to use AI at work and still keep your skills sharp. For listeners who are already using AI in the workplace, what should they keep in? mind to make sure that they're using it in a way that still keeps their skills sharp? I think that it would be good to make decisions that are well-informed. So if this is a skill that you don't care about, then don't worry about it, right? So if it's, for example, you want to spend your time coming up with a new business idea, but you don't want to
在那些人工智能因不同原因而不可用的情况下，仍然能够推理和思考信息。我们将进行短暂的休息。回来后，我将与麦克纳马拉博士讨论如何在工作中利用人工智能并保持技能敏锐。对于已经在工作场所使用人工智能的听众，他们应该记住什么，以确保他们以一种仍然能保持技能敏锐的方式使用它？我认为做出知情的决定会很好。所以如果这是一项你不在乎的技能，那就别担心它，对吧？所以如果，例如，你想花时间想出一个新的商业点子，但你不想
program the budget, for example, you know, come up with the budget. Yeah, maybe using AI for that while you spend your cognitive resources on something else, that might be a good use for you. So it depends on what skills you want to make sure that you maintain. If you want to learn a new skill or you want to make sure that you maintain a new skill, then really thinking about how you use the AI. And I think this is important in the workplace in particular, because the short-term benefits are always going to lead to saying use the AI. Because in the immediate, the short-term effects are, it's probably you're going to get a better result, is probably going to be more efficient, it's going to be less effortful. But long-term, if that's a skill that you don't want to use,
编写预算，例如，你知道，想出预算。是的，也许为此使用人工智能，同时你把认知资源花在其他事情上，这对你来说可能是一个很好的用途。所以这取决于你想确保保持哪些技能。如果你想学习一项新技能，或者你想确保保持一项新技能，那么真正思考你如何使用人工智能。我认为这在工作场所尤其重要，因为短期利益总是会导致说“使用人工智能”。因为在短期内，短期效果是，你可能会得到更好的结果，可能会更有效率，会更省力。但从长远来看，如果那是一项你不想使用的技能，
then maybe think about not using AI every time, testing your skills without AI, or using it in a way where you are generating first and then asking for feedback, where you are interrogating the prompts that you're giving it and the responses that it's giving you, or asking it to fill in gaps that you're missing and the next time try to do it without the AI providing you those cues and see if you can do it. What are you seeing out there as you do research? I mean, our workplaces thinking along these lines as they implement AI procedures at jobs? I think they are. I mean, I'm sure there's a lot of variability and some places probably are thinking about it more or less. And of course, people are using AI in all sorts of very different ways from creative endeavors to, you know, sort of more
那么也许考虑不要每次都使用人工智能，在没有人工智能的情况下测试你的技能，或者以一种你先生成然后寻求反馈的方式使用它，在那里你审视你给它的提示和它给你的回应，或者要求它填补你缺失的空白，下次尝试在没有人工智能提供这些线索的情况下完成它，看看你是否能做到。你在做研究时看到了什么？我的意思是，我们的工作场所是否在实施人工智能程序时考虑到了这些思路？我认为他们是。我的意思是，我相信有很多变数，有些地方可能考虑得更多或更少。当然，人们正在以各种非常不同的方式使用人工智能，从创造性的努力到，你知道，更
procedural endeavors. So, for example, one way that it's being used is in radiology. In radiology, a lot of systems either have just a computer-assisted, device or it is true AI that's helping find abnormalities in an image. Now, it's always the recommendation that radiologists first try to find the abnormalities themselves and then click the button to see what the system says it's there. But again, we don't really know what they're doing. So if they really don't feel like putting in the effort or they're less concerned about their skills, they might just be clicking that button and then hopefully at least checking the work.
程序性的努力。例如，它被使用的一种方式是在放射学中。在放射学中，许多系统要么只有计算机辅助设备，要么是真正的辅助人工智能，帮助在图像中发现异常。现在，总是建议放射科医生首先尝试自己发现异常，然后点击按钮查看系统说那里有什么。但同样，我们真的不知道他们在做什么。所以如果他们真的不想投入精力，或者他们不太关心自己的技能，他们可能只是点击那个按钮，然后希望至少检查一下工作。
And again, immediate reward is that it's less time. They're going to be more efficient and probably have a high success rate in terms of detection. Long term, we want to worry about their skills and making sure that they could still do this without the AI. Because AIs are not perfect.
同样，直接的回报是时间更少。他们会更有效率，并且在检测方面可能有很高的成功率。从长远来看，我们想担心他们的技能，并确保他们仍然可以在没有人工智能的情况下做到这一点。因为人工智能并不完美。
They are fallible and people are fallible. But if we start leaning too much on the AI are forgetting about its fallibility, then we're not putting that shared cognition together. So we have the human intelligence, we have the artificial intelligence. And the idea is if we look first, we're more likely to find something
它们是容易出错的，人也是容易出错的。但如果我们开始太依赖人工智能，而忘记了它的易错性，那么我们就没有把那种共享认知结合在一起。所以我们有人类智能，我们有人工智能。而理念是，如果我们先看，我们更有可能发现一些
that maybe the AI is going to miss. But if we just look at what the AI says, we might not see what we would have caught before. So there's that concern. And people very much differ in how much they are biased towards leaning on an AI versus not. So there's some people who get complacent when an AI is available. There's some work that suggests, and this is in aviation and automation in general,
人工智能可能会遗漏的东西。但如果我们只是看人工智能说了什么，我们可能看不到我们以前会捕捉到的东西。所以存在这种担忧。而且人们在偏向于依赖人工智能与否方面差异很大。所以有些人当人工智能可用时会变得自满。有一些工作表明，这在航空和自动化领域通常是这样，
that once a system is about 70% accurate, people tend to just rely on it. And 70% is still leaving a lot on the table. Some people argue that AI is going to free people from a lot of routine work, what I call the tricky track that you don't want to do so that you can focus more on creative and difficult tasks. So do you think that AI is going to lead more to upskilling than to deskilling? Absolutely in some ways. It's hard to say what that proportion or ratio is, what is going to be more upskilling compared to less deskilling. Certainly it's going to be the case that people will be able to not spend their time on the TDM and might be able to learn new.
一旦系统准确率达到70%左右，人们往往就会依赖它。而70%仍然留下了很多空间。有些人认为人工智能将把人们从许多日常工作中解放出来，我称之为“你不想做的棘手轨道”，这样你就可以更多地专注于创造性和困难的任务。那么你认为人工智能会导致更多的技能提升而不是技能下降吗？在某些方面绝对是。很难说那个比例或比率是多少，什么是更多的技能提升与更少的技能下降。当然，人们将能够不把时间花在乏味的事情上，并且可能能够学习新的
skills that they're more interested in. It's also probably going to be the case that people will lose skills. And as a society, we might be okay with losing those skills. Which one is going to be greater is hard to know. We certainly hope as a society moving forward that it's going to be greater the upskilling than the deskilling. But it's a bit early to tell. Would you come down more on the optimistic side or the pessimistic side based on where we are right now? Well, I think we're going to end up doing both. Lots of things will improve as usually as the case when we have a new technology. We will certainly lose some skills that as a society we might be okay with losing or as an individual, we might be okay losing. What's interesting about AI is some people would say that the argument is it's just another step in technology and it's not really anything special and we'll move forward. in the way that we have with all of these other new technologies.
他们更感兴趣的技能。人们也可能会失去技能。作为一个社会，我们可能愿意接受失去这些技能。哪一个会更大很难知道。我们当然希望作为一个社会向前发展，技能提升会大于技能下降。但现在下结论还为时过早。基于我们现在所处的位置，你会更倾向于乐观的一面还是悲观的一面？嗯，我认为我们最终会两者兼顾。很多事情会改善，就像我们拥有新技术时通常的情况一样。我们肯定会失去一些技能，作为一个社会，我们可能愿意接受失去这些技能，或者作为一个个人，我们可能愿意失去。关于人工智能有趣的是，有些人会说，论点是它只是技术的又一步，它并不是什么特别的东西，我们将向前发展，
Then others would argue that there is something different about AI that unlike other technologies, it's taking components of our cognitive processes that were just not available before, where it is making potentially decisions, expert-level decisions, that we wouldn't have off-floated before that we are now. So there's not only the deskilling concern and the skill decay concern, but there is the overconfidence
就像我们对待所有这些其他新技术一样。然后其他人会争辩说，人工智能确实有一些不同的地方，与其他技术不同，它正在获取我们以前无法获得的认知过程的组成部分，它正在做出潜在的决定，专家级的决定，我们以前不会卸载，但现在我们正在卸载。所以不仅有技能下降的担忧和技能退化的担忧，还有过度自信
concern. There's a concern that maybe we will generally start expecting kind of immediate results more, not wanting to persist as much. There's been a little bit of work already in this space. This is from a pre-print, so of course you have to be careful with that because it hasn't been peer reviewed yet. But across multiple studies, they noted that when they were trying to learn a new problem-solving skill, and they used AI, and they got the answer, and then when it was taken away, people just gave up a lot more quickly. They got used to getting this immediate result,
的担忧。有一种担忧是，也许我们通常会开始期待更多的即时结果，不想坚持那么久。在这个领域已经有一些工作了。这是来自预印本，所以当然你必须小心，因为它还没有经过同行评审。但在多项研究中，他们注意到，当他们试图学习一项新的解决问题的技能时，他们使用了人工智能，他们得到了答案，然后当它被拿走时，人们放弃得更快。他们习惯了得到这种即时结果，
and it just wasn't worth it anymore to put forth the effort. And so there's concerns that this could then spread and be broader. Now, the research is sort of all over the place in terms of whether you try to encourage people to put forth more effort in a task, whether that has far transfer, whether people start persisting more generally. So there's some research that suggests, yes, some says, no, that's not really the case. But the idea is whenever we think that something might improve with an intervention, well, then it might be the same thing, that if we have this intervention in this case, AI, and we're not using a cognitive process. then it might get worse.
而且投入精力已经不值得了。因此，人们担心这可能会扩散并变得更广泛。现在，关于你是否试图鼓励人们在任务中投入更多精力，这是否具有远迁移，人们是否开始更普遍地坚持，研究在某种程度上是各不相同的。所以有一些研究表明，是的，有些说，不，情况并非如此。但理念是，每当我们认为某件事可能会通过干预而改善时，那么它可能是一样的，如果我们在这个案例中有这种干预，即人工智能，而我们没有使用认知过程，那么它可能会变得更糟。
So kind of the opposite of what we usually think of in an intervention. So it's hard to know whether it'll change expectations or habits in terms of diligence and industriousness and persistence and things like that, which is a concern. And maybe that's been a concern with past technologies and there's nothing different here, but these are the current concerns that we're thinking about. do you use AI in the work that you do? I mean, does it assist you in your research or check your, you know, your math for you? Oh, okay. So no, I don't use AI at all. I mean, other than, of course, there's there's parts that you can't get away from. So now you use Google and an AI synopsis comes up. And so I will look at that and I do try to click on the link and actually double check it. I ignore the, the, that you know, the, you know, that email that tries to, you know, you're responding to an email and it tries to finish your sentence for you. I generally say, hey, stop that and do it myself. So no, I'm probably one of the few people
所以这与我们通常在干预中想到的相反。所以很难知道它是否会改变在勤奋、勤勉和坚持等方面的期望或习惯，这令人担忧。也许这在过去的技术中一直是一个担忧，这里没有什么不同，但这些是我们正在考虑的当前担忧。你会在你的工作中使用人工智能吗？我的意思是，它会辅助你的研究或为你检查你的数学吗？哦，好的。所以不，我根本不使用人工智能。我的意思是，当然，除了有些部分你无法逃避。所以现在你使用谷歌，会出现人工智能摘要。所以我看那个，我确实尝试点击链接并实际仔细检查它。我忽略了那个，你知道，那个试图，你知道，你正在回复一封电子邮件，它试图为你完成句子的电子邮件。我通常说，嘿，停下来，我自己做。所以不，我可能是少数几个
studying AI and not using AI. Perhaps as somebody who studies skills and performance and offloading, I'm sort of just not willing to offload at this point. That might change, I might just be, you know. Resisting the inevitable. Right, exactly, exactly. So we'll see. But I don't want to come across as just sort of anti any kind of new technology because I think there are absolutely benefits that come with it. What are you working on now? What are the big questions that you're trying to answer? So one of the questions that I'm working on with colleagues from computer science and medicine and robotics is looking at AI skill development, particularly in radiology and surgical robotics, skilled maintenance in those areas. So do we see skill decay?
研究人工智能而不使用人工智能的人。也许作为一个研究技能、表现和卸载的人，我目前只是不愿意卸载。这可能会改变，我可能只是，你知道。抵抗不可避免的事情。没错，完全正确，完全正确。所以我们会看到的。但我不想给人留下我只是反对任何新技术的印象，因为我认为它绝对带来了好处。你现在在做什么？你正在试图回答哪些大问题？所以，我正在与来自计算机科学、医学和机器人技术的同事一起研究的问题之一是观察人工智能技能发展，特别是在放射学和手术机器人领域，这些领域的技能维护。所以我们看到了技能退化吗？
And then overconfidence. So we've been collecting data on that for about a year. We're getting close. And it's still preliminary at this case. So I don't want to get into results. it might be potentially the case that we should have some concerns about AI in terms of our confidence and our learning. So that's something that I've been working on with AI. And then with Evan Riscoe, who studies cognitive offloading, we're planning a series of studies to look more at some of these studies that have come out and looking at, you know, longer scales of skill acquisition, other ways that cognitive offloading might change how people interact with AI. So just sort of joining what a lot of people are studying this topic at this point.
然后是过度自信。所以我们已经收集了大约一年的相关数据。我们快要完成了。而且目前还是初步的。所以我不想深入讨论结果。在人工智能方面，我们可能应该对我们的自信和学习有一些担忧。所以这是我一直在研究人工智能的事情。然后与研究认知卸载的埃文·里斯科（Evan Riscoe）一起，我们计划进行一系列研究，以更多地观察已经出现的一些研究，并观察，你知道，更长期的技能获取，认知卸载可能改变人们与人工智能互动方式的其他方式。所以只是加入到目前为止研究这个主题的许多人中。
It's just that there's lots of new studies coming out. But even though I say lots, we're so new. It's just these one-off studies on this one topic here and there, that we're getting to where we really have a broader knowledge base about it, but we're not there yet. Anything you want our listeners to know that I didn't get around to asking you? Sure. One thing that Evan Riscoe and I have been talking about and some of his colleagues is the likely difference in effects of using AI on skills and knowledge versus basic cognitive
只是有很多新的研究出来。但即使我说很多，我们还是太新了。这只是这里和那里关于这个主题的个别研究，我们正在达到我们真正拥有更广泛知识基础的地步，但我们还没有达到。有什么你想让我们的听众知道而我没有问你的吗？当然。埃文·里斯科和我以及他的一些同事一直在谈论的一件事是，使用人工智能对技能和知识与基本认知
abilities. So skills and knowledge are both acquired primarily through practice, through experience, right? There's some kind of innate knowledge, but for the most part, when we acquire knowledge, we have to have some sort of experience where we learn it. And likewise with skills, we're not born knowing how to play chess, for example. We need to practice that. Now, it's not that that is 100% of it. People vary in how quickly they learn, for example. So it's not that practice explains 100% of our skills. But, it does explain, for the most part, changes within a person. So if I practice the piano, tomorrow, I'm probably going to be a little bit better than I was today, and so on. So there's
能力的影响可能存在差异。所以技能和知识都是主要通过练习、通过经验获得的，对吧？有一些天生的知识，但在大多数情况下，当我们获得知识时，我们必须有某种经验来学习它。同样，对于技能，我们不是生来就知道如何下棋，例如。我们需要练习它。现在，并不是说这就是100%。人们学习的速度各不相同，例如。所以并不是说练习解释了我们技能的100%。但是，它在很大程度上解释了个人内部的变化。所以如果我练习钢琴，明天我可能会比今天好一点，以此类推。所以有
skills and knowledge are very sensitive to our experiences and therefore potentially how much we're offloading. Basic cognitive abilities or fundamental cognitive abilities, foundational abilities, again, these are not perfect distinctions. And of course, There's bleeding into skills and abilities. But broadly speaking, abilities are kind of more stable, sort of your reasoning ability, your working memory capacities, sort of how much information you hold in your mind. And of course, there's development as kids. And of course, there's declines at older age.
技能和知识对我们的经验非常敏感，因此可能对我们卸载了多少非常敏感。基本认知能力或基本认知能力、基础能力，同样，这些不是完美的区分。当然，有渗入技能和能力的情况。但广义上讲，能力更稳定，比如你的推理能力、你的工作记忆容量，比如你脑中持有的信息量。当然，孩子有发展。当然，老年时有衰退。
But broadly, there have been a lot of interventions trying to improve basic cognitive of abilities. And while at first some of those studies looked promising, usually it's the case that they were unable to have far transfer, right? So we have people do a task that's designed to increase their working memory capacity, and then we see if they're better on an intelligence test. And it's really hard to find that far transfer. So it suggests that we're fairly insensitive to our experiences with those cognitive abilities. So for a lot of people, that was bad news, right? For a lot of people, we wanted to get smarter by doing brain training. And that seemed like a great thing to do. The promising side of this, of course, is that if these abilities are fairly insensitive to experience,
但广义上，已经有很多干预措施试图改善基本认知能力。虽然起初一些研究看起来很有希望，但通常情况是它们无法实现远迁移，对吧？所以我们让人做一项旨在增加其工作记忆容量的任务，然后我们看看他们在智力测试中是否表现更好。而且真的很难找到那种远迁移。所以这表明我们对那些认知能力的经验相当不敏感。所以对很多人来说，那是坏消息，对吧？对很多人来说，我们想通过大脑训练变得更聪明。这看起来是一件很棒的事情。当然，这其中有希望的一面是，如果这些能力对经验相当不敏感，
then we probably don't have to worry as much about our intelligence getting worse with AI. Because if It's insensitive, more insensitive to experiences. It's probably not going to be the case that we use AI and now we just can't think anymore. So skills and knowledge acquisition, much more sensitive to experience and probably much more sensitive to how we use AI in terms of maintaining and acquiring. But basic cognitive abilities we might be a little bit safer about. Well, sounds like we need to talk again in another year or two. how things are going. Absolutely. Yes, I'll give the caveat that all of this is new. I could be
那么我们可能不必太担心我们的智力会随着人工智能而变差。因为如果它是对经验不敏感，更不敏感。我们使用人工智能而现在我们只是无法再思考的情况可能不会发生。所以技能和知识获取，对经验敏感得多，并且可能对我们在维护和获取方面如何使用人工智能敏感得多。但基本认知能力我们可能稍微安全一点。嗯，听起来我们需要在一年或两年后再谈谈。事情进展如何。当然。是的，我会给出一个警告，所有这些都是新的。我可能
completely wrong about everything that I'm saying. Well, I doubt that, but I want to thank you for joining me, Dr. McMur. This has been very interesting. Thank you. Thank you so much for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman.
对我所说的一切完全错误。嗯，我对此表示怀疑，但我还是要感谢您的加入，麦克纳马拉博士。这非常有趣。谢谢。非常感谢您的邀请。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢您所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您有对未来播客的评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。
Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。